dude it's another wild ride and this
week is special
because it's not just one super
interesting
totally dynamic professional
skateboarder on this episode
there's two who's the other one me
that's right
as you're about to learn i have made
myself a professional
signature skateboard stevo skateboard
yeah i went into the factory where they
made them and signed everyone before
they got shrink wrapped
of course we did a very small run
very few available at stevo.com but i
wanted you podcast
people to know about it first so if you
want to get a signature stevo skateboard
go to stevo.com
but more importantly ladies and
gentlemen
ryan sheckler you yeah dude
[ __ ] right on bro soaked man
dude so psyched right here in the rv
is like a hundred skateboards i turned
myself
pro got the stevo skateboard right here
in my hand i have not yet set foot on it
and we're parked right outside brian's
training facility that's what you call
it oh yeah i mean skate park training
facility whatever
whatever you want to call it man we use
it for uh for everything man
so you turned yourself pro yeah has it
ever been done before in the history of
skateboarding
i'm sure people have turned themselves
i mean they might have turned themselves
pro but no one
turns pro and then prints 100 of their
own board
and
i went into the actual manufacturer
and signed every one of them before they
were shrink-wrapped
is that something you're going to do the
whole time you're always going to do oh
dude i do it was a lot of [ __ ] work
man
was it yeah dude imagine how many boards
tony has to sign are like
dude whenever we have to do like a uh or
we do a cool
you know drop for plan b it's like a
thousand boards and
you think it's nothing to really sign a
thousand but right once you have
like you forget how much 100 skateboards
weighs like that's a lot of weight
i know then to unwrap them sign them
re-wrap them re-put them back in the box
like it's it's gnarly well dude he just
signed how many
how many prints did you just signed last
night well the last couple days i signed
1260 prints of those wall ride photos oh
sick yeah that photo turned out rad i
was
hyped to be there that day dude and
that's only half
of uh we got 2500 of them were you were
you signing [ __ ] at 13
ryan dude you're probably saying [ __ ] at
eight yeah at eight
yeah it was it was crazy because like
dude i started competing when i was
seven
and um you know from there i
really realized how much i enjoyed
competing
it was super scary to me but it was also
like this mental
it was like a mental challenge to
overcome
the nerves that i was feeling i guess
and dude before contest i would
i would have to go behind the ramps and
i would like cry because i was so
nervous
and it wasn't because i didn't want to
be there it was just because i like
cared so damn much and uh yeah from that
point on dude it was just like
kept moving up in the ranks in the
california amateur skateboarding league
and then
won the uh one factory this like factory
division which was like the sponsor
division when i was 12 and then that got
me invited
to x games and slam city jam and the
vans triple crown and i think there was
one more like gravity games
and that year of 13 man i won every
single pro
contest and i only won man because i was
having fun there was no expectations
there was nothing on my mind
except for i was just a stoked little
kid
that got the opportunity to go skate
with the best dudes that i looked up to
and it just worked out you know it just
worked out i couldn't fall
it was weird you're saying you won every
pro contest when you were 13.
yeah every pro contest that there was uh
the 13th year of my life
[Laughter]
which was champions 2003 that's the only
one that's the only one i didn't get
invited to because i
tampo tampa was weird about you had to
be pro to be in the tampa pro and so i
skated tampa am
earlier that year because it's like the
first contest of the year
and uh didn't do very well and then
ended up winning
all the pro contests epic dude jesus
dude
so man i think i was so excited about
doing this with you because i mean for a
million reasons obviously but
what a huge part of my history
you played by being on the cover of the
issue of big brother magazine
yeah which just fired up all this
controversy and for anybody who doesn't
know what big brother magazine is
this was a skateboarding magazine which
was for no purpose other than to just be
filthy inappropriate like just
bad you know like they just did all this
bad
[ __ ] and it was the people who ran big
brother magazine who went on to start
jackass
so this is like the origins of jackass
and
the cover of big brother that had
ryan sheckler on it how old are you then
i was eight
eight so yeah was that your first front
cover that was my first cover
but like the fact that it was big
brother who was also run by hustler
magazine you know larry flynn well no no
but that's the thing that was the
the it wasn't yet uh owned by larry
flint oh it wasn't yet it wasn't and the
thing was big brother was all
controversial to begin with like they
had these articles on like the 10 most
effective ways to kill yourself and they
were
dead serious about it dude yeah i wasn't
allowed to read it
i wasn't around like at all allowed to
read anything
that was in that magazine i could look
at the cover and that was it
um even the covers were wildly
inappropriate but even
even the magazine you're on the cover of
you couldn't read no absolutely not no
it was all over the news
like it was on the news and it was like
because then the
reporters started actually reading the
interview questions that they were like
asking these you know
i was the i don't think i was the
youngest there was like a six-year-old
and then it went up to like 13 and 14
but like
you know the 12 and 13 year olds are
asking them about like do you have pubic
hair yeah like
would you [ __ ] your mom yeah like if it
would magically make you a pro
skateboarder would you [ __ ] your own
mother
chris morocco who knows dude it was just
like
and so already big brother magazine was
in all kinds of trouble anyway
yeah but then when now they got the
[ __ ] kids it was called the kids
issue
yeah it's purely [ __ ] kids and
big brother's doing its thing so it's
all over the news there's all this
outrage
it was crazy there's so much controversy
in the media about big brother magazine
for the kids issue
that larry flint the famous pornographer
hustler magazine guy who's a big first
amendment dude
he was he heard a bit he says man i
[ __ ] dig this
so larry flint buys big brother magazine
now there's like 27 porno magazines
and one skateboard magazine like put out
by larry flint
yeah and um the the irony of it was that
before
larry flint bought it it was filled with
actual nudity
all kinds of and then at once larry
flint bought it
then uh the no more nudity and it
actually cleaned it up a little bit that
was a rule
larry flint made like you know because
that's illegal
oh okay it was just a [ __ ] illegal
thing dude
and uh it was ryan's covered
ryan's issue got the attention of larry
flynn larry flint bought it
became a bigger like more thing and then
jackass started because of that
wow all because of you ryan it was wild
man it's like the only time you could
ever get a melon grab
on the cover of a magazine and dude it
was eight years old man i had no idea
but yeah dave carney and all the boys
yeah those wild times man
yeah chris norako did you see the the
documentary about big brother magazine
no i haven't seen it yet dude it's
[ __ ] crazy man
i i still haven't seen it where can you
see it it's on hulu it's called
dumb and it's uh the story of big
brother magazine and really what it is
is a jackass origin
story and the thing about jackass is
it's like kind of wholesome because like
we don't we're not mean to anybody else
we only really do [ __ ] up [ __ ] to
ourselves like it's in a good spirit
but big brother magazine was not that
way dude and when i went to the premiere
for the dumb documentary like
it it [ __ ] shook me up
i was like i was like dude you put that
whole story all into one documentary and
it's like
upsetting how [ __ ] awful it was
it's just bad [ __ ] not a good spirit all
bad things
geez yeah but so that that's when you
were eight
you turned pro when you were 13. yeah
then how old were you when you got the
mtv show like 16.
uh i was just turning 17. so we went
through the whole like doing the um
you know doing the pilot episode uh it
was yeah i just turned
17 when they actually were like okay
we're we're gonna do this
and uh we want three seasons and
at that point like i didn't really know
much about television but i figured
three seasons is pretty good and
uh we have something good yeah we had
you know we had fun you know but it was
a super controversial
time in my life um
because i was known as like a contest
skater
i had a couple video parts and
i was doing really well like i was i was
known as a skateboarder
and then this opportunity came up where
we were already like flying crazy places
like flying private
and you know having parties and having
fun but still winning the contest
and they picked up on that and like the
dynamic between me and my family and me
and my friends was like
it was entertaining it was definitely
entertaining and they wanted it and uh
so we did it and the first season was
awesome man we were getting like 2.6
million viewers
per episode roughly we were on friday
night at like 10 o'clock so it was like
and that's when you had to like
sit at home and watch tv you know it
wasn't like no social media or anything
like that we were actually getting like
two million
you know authentic views which was crazy
and so
mtv ate it up i ended up too because it
was like now all of a sudden we're like
have budget to actually go take a
private plane to a contest which was
crazy
showing up at a contest with four camera
guys and you know the pas and the sound
guys and like we had
a posse deep of 25 always so it was it
was just a scene you know and
um did the show but
in the actual skateboarding community it
caused a little bit of a
like uproar you know like people were
truly convinced that i was like
destroying skateboarding and my whole
thing was like man skateboarding such a
freedom
and it's based on how you feel on your
board how i feel on my board it's such
an individual sport that like not one
person
can destroy something that's so pure and
so like free for everyone yeah and
what were you destroying about that's
just people being haters you know yeah
and i realized that now you know i'm 30
now and it's
it's crazy thinking that you know the
show was 12 years ago 13 years ago
um what was i destroying i i don't know
at that point i couldn't even tell man
all i thought
was that i was introducing introducing
skateboarding to kids that would have
never
otherwise picked it up or even were
curious about it you know but they were
watching mtv
so they saw it you know and i don't know
man it was a weird time but i
i don't regret it at all you know if
anything it
it's created such an incredible fan base
for me that that has stuck around
since i was a kid and you know it it was
a show before
it got it wasn't a crazy show you know
yeah there was drama and there was
things of that nature but i always kept
my my morals and and
how i wanted my family to be treated i
kept that
super straight the whole time and i
treated my family with the utmost
respect and especially like
dude mtv's wet dream was my parents
getting a divorce
on the show you know and i had no idea
that was gonna happen
i couldn't even see it coming honestly
and uh
yeah my parents split up and uh i was
destroyed bro
i was destroyed and so that was you know
what what season was that oh i'm sorry
yeah
uh that would have been like end of it
might have been in the second season
so you're like 18 when your parents
split no i was uh
in my parents split when i was 17. so i
had i had like four months left of being
to like by i just remember because i
wanted to move out immediately
you know like they got divorced and i
wanted out because of that yeah
how much time was in between filming
seasons would you like film a season
then you're off
for like nine months and then again or
you just kept filming no we did it we
filmed back to back yeah it was all back
that's how we got three seasons done
before i was even 19
right and by the third season i was i
was over it you know
i was just over it it was crazy of like
you know how it goes dude like i was
waking up
to three cameras almost every day and it
was like
a monday through friday thing and then
you know having to like reshoot breaking
up with girls that i really cared about
you know
right yeah oh my god so you broke up
with a girl and they were like can we
get that again one more
yeah that happened twice dude and i was
like man [ __ ] this dude like oh my gosh
were you like are you serious are you
like contractually you have to
i mean i didn't even know if it was
contractually i wasn't even thinking
like that then i was just like man i
guess if it's like
[ __ ] so i would like take the mic off go
explain
to my girlfriend what had just happened
and like still we're breaking up like
we're broke up
but i need you to be a team player and
like i need you to be a team player you
got to break up again
who broke up with who you broke up with
i had to break i was always breaking up
with the girls [ __ ]
yeah man man it was rough dude it was
rough
it was rough for sure but you know i
don't take any of it for granted it was
a
it was a wild experience you know it
definitely shaped a lot of of who i am
today and
experiences that i somewhat don't want
to get back into i've been offered to do
a tv show again and i'm like nah you
know like
i'm working on our own things in here
doing the sandlot time so it's like it's
a lot more fun and it's a lot more
100 of our control that's the main thing
we need to have control of what we're
what we're putting out
so did your skateboarding
it didn't suffer at all for the for the
mtv show going on
i don't think it suffered at all if
anything i think it made me skate even
gnarlier because i knew i had a
huge audience watching me skate you know
it's like you do these video parts and
you know maybe a couple million people
see them over over years but like man we
were having a couple million people
watching skateboarding
every friday and so i was like hyped
plus that's
just the first time it airs then you've
got all the reruns like and tv
played a million times so by the time
the shows were on its course with all
the reruns included
like way more people oh yeah for sure
and so like i was psyched i was like man
and my skating was on point like dude it
was
the glory years for sure like 15 to 15
to 20
23 24 was like those are the best years
of my life that i i
i think of you know skating wise and now
you know it's like
went through the sobriety thing and you
know got caught up with drinking and
had to figure that whole side out and
you know
at 30 right now
being sober and fully
comfortable in my skin and who i am now
i feel like the second chapter of my
life
is 10 times better than that first one i
feel way more confident now
and just more comfortable with my
skateboarding and there's no second
guessing
and so you know i'm working on a red
bull video part right now that
to me is some of the best is the best
skateboarding that i've ever done
dude it's so rad um i i
asked you last week like what
what it's been like with your injuries
and you reeled off
like yeah pretty horrifying
but despite all of your injuries
actually just run them down real quick
you know one injury that i'm really
grateful to say i have not
sustained is hair loss man
and you know having hair it's such a
treat
and why not make it look good right do
you have hair
why don't you make it look good how are
we gonna do that boys
well i'll tell you we got a new sponsor
of the show
it's called fix your lid
this is what it's all about gentlemen
styling
now their products are 100
cruelty free right that means no animal
testing
no none of that nonsense we love animals
okay
also 100 made in america
yeah that's kind of cool too isn't it so
here we go i'm gonna go with a medium
hold
forming cream just because that's what
i'm talking about okay
oh yeah now how are you gonna get these
products i'm gonna tell you right now
you go to shop fix your lid.com
okay and use the promo code stevo
that's going to get you 10 off your
order
plus if you do so right now
and go ahead and do that as a supporter
of the wild ride podcast
because when you do that make your order
you are
automatically entered to win one of
these
super dope coolers
fix your lid branded signed by
me and it will be
filled with fix your lid
products yeah dude
so one more time we're going to shop
fixyourlid.com
enter the promo code stevo
and we get 10 off our order
and we're automatically entered to win
one of these
super killer coolers
so get on it and do it right now
now let's hear about injuries
yeah man so i mean the most the most
recent one i broke both my ankles
and fractured my l1 in my back on one
fall
fell 16 feet and completely
had to get reconstructive surgery on the
right ankle the left ankle kind of just
like
smashed together so it was i didn't need
to surgery on that no back surgery
broke my left elbow six times right
elbow
four times with plates and screws in
here
liz frank injury on my right foot
completely separated the first
metatarsal and
had to get that that was like that took
over a year to heal
um both both mcl's
both meniscus jesus just got mris today
for my acl my left knee
concussions three concussions two of
them hospitalized and like dude
it doesn't matter i i get more angry at
myself that i'm like
[ __ ] you let yourself get hurt again
like okay physical therapy we'll be back
in
you know three months six months at the
most
but and despite all the injuries like
i mean i've seen you skate like it's not
it doesn't it doesn't affect me you know
it's like even with this knee that i'm
dealing with right now
is like it's not really a big deal it's
only a big deal if i'm like jumping off
something big and i catch it a weird way
and it sends this like
nerve pain from my hip all the way down
to my toes and then i just gotta lay
down
kind of let it chill for 10 minutes and
then all the feeling comes back and then
like
then i can skate again while the
adrenaline's high but
you know sometimes i have to take a day
off and i i only got mri today just
because i've i've been like curious like
why does it allow me to to skate
but then sometimes it doesn't so it's a
weird thing man the more you get injured
the more you realize about your body
wendy for sure
wendy just farted for sure hey there's a
wild ride first
that's that's a dog fight yeah dude
wendy party big time
wow i'm so glad i've never been more
happy to be up in the front of
oh my god can you turn it up a notch or
maybe open up the door
[Laughter]
oh we're in our started waters right
here all right i'm gonna open up the
door a little bit
okay i'm gonna good i'm gonna turn this
up a little
i got dogs man it's dot dude i set up
this board today and
just started daydreaming about tricks
that i want to pull in your spot here
yeah man we're gonna get you in there
that's step up step up the step up that
i ollied
last time i want to kickflip that i know
i know you do
i'm sorry i know you do and i want i
want you to do that as well
that that clip they played of you on
ridiculousness
i think you kick flipped over the
14-foot landing or something
like that costco gap yeah i mean was
that the first attempt
or is that because that [ __ ] was
gnarly that was the fourth attempt
that was the fourth attempt on that one
and uh the that day played out super
crazy
we had been we had been partying the
night before
and that that's one of those tricks
where like any of my super big tricks
i don't plan to go do them i like i have
to wake up and be
feeling a certain way and just
[ __ ] amped up and i woke up and i was
amped up and i hit up the photographer
and hit up my filmer and i was like hey
i want to go
because i had ollie did previously and
it took me five tries to ollie it
like four years before that for an
oakley video that i was doing
and so i just randomly woke up and
thought about that spot
we showed up there and my whole deal was
like if i don't ollie at first try
today is not the day and i already first
try and stomped it and was like
okay i guess today's the day and yeah
four tries and like the attempts for
are gnarly like yeah i exploded i
exploded and
the one i rolled away from was just like
i couldn't have done it any better yeah
i couldn't have
seen that i'm sure i have yeah it's uh
you landed it so clean and your knees
went straight to your chest and you just
popped up yeah like
i mean and even on the roll away like i
couldn't believe i was rolling away
that that was at the the ultimate i
think that was
as much impact as i could possibly take
yeah you said
one of your buddies just jumped off it
it wasn't even a both of his legs yeah
it wasn't even a buddy dude it was just
some random dude that my homies were
like hey you have to check out this kid
on youtube uh talking he was talking
about me
saying that it wasn't that big of a deal
and then he went
he went and he just ran and jumped over
it and yeah
broke both his [ __ ] ankles man oh no
way yeah
yeah it's gnarly how old were you when
you did that i was
in between surgery number 34 and 36.
i think i was 19 or 20. yeah
i uh shattered my ankle doing this
boneless hop a porta potty with danny
way crashing a card through it
i saw that and uh so i had to go get
surgery
and danny took me to his surgeon dr
prebyte has that guy done any of
yours no but i do know prevent i know
prevent
great doctor he's a great doctor it's
crazy how how
much i believe in my ankle after that
well yeah when you have a good surgeon
it's like it's on you know the same
dude's done
all of my surgeries dr warren kramer up
in newport he's
like he's a surfer he's just a cool guy
but he's a smart cat and he understands
that like athletes are going to keep
moving and he knows we're going to keep
moving
and so he does surgeries that are not
going to like lock you up and tie you up
and
i got really lucky that that he's my
surgeon and it's crazy to say that you
have a surgeon
yeah right you have to get injured a lot
to have like a guy
like i got him on speed dial and i hit
him up last night i'm like hey man
i know you're busy any time this week
he's like yeah for you come in tomorrow
and i was like
perfect man you know it's got like the
stamp like neck surgery is for a year or
something
i just yeah i wish right that's funny my
insurance would love that
you have a surgeon on speed dial we have
a bail bondsman on speed dial for
hey man you know to each their own for
sure it's not a bail bondsman but my
criminal attorney i have a good
relationship with
you know and we also have a couple uh
that one trick that bailed you out last
time that's just yeah
yeah i have a question about
skateboarding like you talked about when
you hit that
land and you're like you couldn't even
believe you're rolling away
like how often does it happen where your
muscle memory carries you through
something but your brain hasn't even
processed it to like
does or does it happen like that or is
it like while you're like
doing some crazy trick you're like so in
it that's a good question
um i i think it's like really about
being present you know i think it's the
more
the scarier the trick is for me the more
present my brain
automatically snaps into where it's like
i can hear
anything going on i can see the cars
coming from up and down the street but i
also know like i can see my grip tape
like the sparkles on my grip tape where
it's like it's things you would never
really notice but you're so
in tune with what's going on it's also a
big reason that like i don't really
ollie thinks like that's why that ollie
was so important to me it's because
if i ollie something it's like that's
where i can actually lose track of my
mind
is because there's nothing going on it's
just a
free fall and i get the tendency to like
shake my feet or like
i'll bail big ollies but if i kick flip
or if i flip my board
my brain has so much more to think about
and
all of a sudden i flip it catch it
and then i'm rolling away instead of
just like awling and like doo doo doo
you know like free falling so do you
prefer
kick flipping i prefer kick flipping or
flipping my board
down big things um it keeps my mind
keeps my mind focused
anytime i just ollie something i'm like
space cadet
you're like in the air like did i leave
the faucet on or like something similar
you know
like you start second guessing that you
know how to ollie and it's like oh
but then you try kick flip and you get
close you don't have time to yeah
there's no second guess time yeah wow so
in a competition when you're on a run
do you know what tricks you're gonna do
ahead of time or is it yeah in the
moment yeah yeah no the
the runs for me like some people can do
that some people just have it like that
where they can like
you know like a shot where he can get on
a skate park
any course have zero practice and skate
a one minute run and it looks like he's
been on that
you know course for the last week
practicing that run
and then he'll switch it up the next
three runs in a row and you're like man
how did you do that
for me i have to go in there and kind of
map it out you know i'll map out two
runs and hopefully i get my first one
and then you can build on that from
there i kind of play the game with runs
but
um for me i can't just go in like cold
turkey and just be like i'm just gonna
skate
for a minute and see what happens like i
like to plan it out because i want to
get
as many tricks into a run as i possibly
can
like good tricks you know so it tripped
me out when you said that your parents
divorced
on tv yeah and then
here's my [ __ ] crazy thought that i
had
like well at that point your parents are
divorcing
you're wildly successful making i can
only presume
millions and millions of dollars every
year that is like
and and i guess you are an adult at that
point
or you're seventeen years i was still
living at my mom's house yeah
so did your like earnings
like play into your parents divorce
were they like dividing up [ __ ] that you
earned if you're just
listening to this podcast on a platform
other than youtube which of course
allows you to see me
then you aren't aware of how good i look
not just because i styled my hair today
but because i'm staying on top of my
fitness
how with a whoop strap i wear it on my
right wrist
it's the greatest fitness tracking
device out there
it works as a membership service sign up
for the membership and you get the strap
for free you wear the strap and it gives
you incredible insights
into your rest your sleep your recovery
your strain your activities plus i never
have to take it off because i keep the
charger right in my pocket and it slides
right on top boom charging
yeah dude i really like this company man
i really like their product and i want
you to try it
plus i just came up with a pretty crazy
idea which
you're gonna hear about soon yeah you
want to get on this whoop
program okay so go to woop.com
that's w-h-o-o-p dot-com
and you use the promo code stevo and
that gets you 15
off at checkout again that's 15
off at checkout if you use the promo
code stevo
woop.com why are you going to do it
because you want to look good
like me yeah you want to be fit man you
want to be healthy you want to know
what's going on with your body
so get on that whoop program whoop.com
promo code stevo
and get ready to find out the crazy idea
that i came up with all right now let's
get an answer to this awful question i
asked
no no because i've always dude and
shout out to you know steve astafin
who's been my agent since i was you know
13 years old 14 years old
um i've always had my money's always
been like tied up where it's supposed to
be where
my parents couldn't touch it you know
and by the way
apologies for that shitty question no
it's all good you know like that's just
curiosity so was your mom embezzling for
you
no no no no i wasn't suggesting that but
it's just like you know i couldn't help
but be curious yeah no
my parents were both very successful and
you know my mom's been my manager
since i was eight years old and so um
we worked together my dad had you know
thriving companies so he was fine like
everyone was good with money and they
were all they're
both very smart so they had you know
different accounts set up for me and you
know
all my retirement was set up when i was
young like so
by the time i turned 18 like they had
not touched any of my money if anything
they were telling me to save more
because i was spending
money like crazy you know i was 17 with
a tv show
and able to travel wherever and able to
get into
clubs it was like a whole cheese crazy
it was a whole different
you know whole different beast were you
making money at it like eight
i started making money when i was
probably like
i mean yeah i did a couple like little
like game show
like uh because i'm like what is an
eight-year-old buy with a [ __ ] load of
money he was like i have a million
pieces of bubble gum or like yeah
no no man that's how much of a
skateboard i was anything i made i spent
at the skate shop
oh wow yeah i wanted boards and i wanted
new helmets and
you know i wanted i wanted all of it i
got a board for you bro
i know signed and everything yeah but i
bought
like things kids want you know like i
bought remote control cars and like i
would buy my brother a remote control
car and like i
i liked video like toys and bikes yeah
like a bike i got a really cool like red
line bicycle
like i remember getting bicycles and
skateboards and just like toys man it
was all toys
for sure fun dude it was fun yeah [ __ ]
what up
what like what kind of crazy cars have
you had uh crazy cars man
uh when i was 18 i bought a ferrari
uh 4 30. that thing was fun super fun
um had three how fast have you gone to
net
in the ferrari i only went about 150.
the thing was so close to the ground and
it was so
like it was so violent and the the
shifting was just violent it was
actually kind of scary
it's kind of a scary car um so you kept
it at a modest 150
[Laughter]
yeah yeah about about a buck 50 in that
thing but
my favorite cars have been the uh the
s65
uh the amg mercedes benz i've had three
of those things and man
they are that they're rocket ships dude
for a four-door sedan it's a rocket ship
and
my last one i had i tuned it up and was
pushing out
a little over 800 horsepower and hit 176
miles an hour in that thing and it was
like
where wild pico no not on pico no just
headed down south so crazy dude but yeah
it's a quick blast you know but that car
is crazy because the faster you go the
more the suspension
lowers the car and the steering gets
tighter it's like it's race car
that's sick but it's four-door you know
it's it's a sleeper definitely a sleeper
so what's your car right now and then
now i just drive the uh the ford raptor
yeah that's the only car you have yeah
it's the only car i have right now level
how's uh how's sobriety going i mean
like uh you know they say
no dating within your first year
sobriety are you staying true to that or
you
no man i i started dating uh
i started dating my girlfriend in uh
january
so she's been with me through kind of
the uh
the start of this uh the restart i
should say
of the sobriety and man we vibe we vibe
great together
and uh that hasn't been an issue for me
at all
how public have you been about sobriety
like i heard scott asked that question
and i think like whoa whoa whoa like i
don't i don't even know if we won't even
be talking about you've been pretty
public and we can cut it out if you
don't want to no
and dude i've been public about it you
know i i tried you know so
so 18 18 to 25 was uh was pretty heavy
times you know
it was fun it was fun times i i was uh i
was definitely abusing alcohol
and uh got to the point where i had had
enough pain and i needed a break so i
checked into rehab
uh when i was 20 right when i turned 26
i did a 30-day stay and then made it
almost four years
sober and
didn't have a really good program though
didn't have a sponsor
wasn't hitting meetings was just trying
to pretty much white knuckle it
and uh decided that for you know my 30th
birthday
that you know i wanted to go have fun
phone with my homies say and and see if
i could drink again
and i ended up drinking and
just it just became this like this crazy
thing where
it was all i could think about was
drinking and it wasn't the amount
it wasn't you know getting blacked out
or going crazy it was just the fact that
i could not get it off my mind and it
was one of those things where it was
like
every day was coming around once four
o'clock hit
it was like all i could think about was
a drink i was starting to do
things during the day getting my
business done but i was like almost
doing things
as like trying to get a reward you know
i was trying to do things to be like
okay cool
satisfied i did that now my reward is
this and i wasn't dealing with
a lot of the i wasn't dealing with a lot
of the real feelings the real life
feelings that i needed to be dealing
with
so you know coming into it now
six months so far of 100 sobriety
again with the solid program with sober
friends
doing what i'm supposed to be doing
going through the steps
it's the best thing i've ever done for
sure [ __ ] epic dude
um so you said that the the life of ryan
mtv show
it helped your skateboarding
but how about like the drinking was it
when you were abusing alcohol are you uh
like just able to get away with it like
skateboarding wise
yeah man cause i was i was like i was
young
dude like i don't know my body hadn't
been taxed enough
from the actual drinking that like man i
was still able to like
i was still able to like go party wake
up the next day a little bit hungover
but like a psyched hank you know i was
like a psyched hangover i wanted to
skate i wanted to skate something gnarly
and i wanted to do it right then and
there like
wouldn't wait for the photographer to
set up wouldn't wait for the filmer to
set up would just start
jumping down 15 stairs and you know that
went on for years dude
that went on for years and i look back
at it now and i don't regret it you know
it got me to this point where i'm at
today where i'm so blessed and so
thankful to be a professional
skateboarder to still be in the mix to
still be
filming and like to have the sheckler
foundation to
be giving back to so many different
types of communities that i had to go
through that pain man i had to go
through those trials and tribulations
that
that were set in front of me and you
know what's the
what's the shekler foundation all about
so scheckler foundation
basically we um we do a lot of work with
uh ascape autism skates the adaptive
adaptive crew which are the guys that
are running around in the wheelchairs
and you know guys that are missing limbs
and skating with prosthetics and
um inner city kids we we help build
skate parks
and we just help give back to uh to
at-risk youth man
to to kids that that need a shot and
do a lot of work with the hospitals and
children's hospitals and
it's been something that you know
started when i was 17 years old because
i got to
i got the opportunity to grant a wish
for make-a-wish foundation
uh to this girl named casey out in texas
and uh
she had leukemia and and it was so crazy
man because she was so happy and such a
like
such a rad spirit and you know she'd
been going through chemo and
shouldn't have been in the mood that she
was in like that's what i thought and
she told me that she just she wanted to
hang out with me for the day
because she respected how i treated my
my family and my brothers
after my parents got divorced and so it
was like this
this whole thing of like man i thought
my life was like kind of in in shambles
when that started happening and it was
so public but she told me that she found
strength in that and
from that day forward all i wanted to do
is i want to give back to the fans and
to the people
that have allowed me to live this life
that i live and
um so yeah man we've been running
running 13 years strong struck the
foundation and
donated a couple million dollars and wow
yeah we're just we're helping man our
whole initiative is you know be the
change you want to see in your community
so
um you know we do we do a huge call to
action
once a year where you know we we just
get everyone from from
america just kind of hitting us up with
what they want to see change
in their community and how we can help
with whether it's skate park or hospital
or you know building a safe place like
safe playgrounds and things like that it
doesn't always have to be skateboarding
it's just kind of
what's on your guys's mind man we're
here for the community so do you have a
call to action coming up soon or did you
guys already do one this year we just
did
we did our uh skate for a cause tour
and we did a 10-stop tour where each
stop we donated 10 grand
to uh to the winners that we had picked
um
through our call to action and uh it was
cool we took a big tour bus and we just
freaking traveled across america man it
was awesome and we stopped in on places
that we had already
previously donated to in the uh in the
years before and
um just kind of did checkups and
just kept the vibe right you know and
it's super cool because we will do it
where it's like
we'll show up at a spot we'll do the 10
grant but it's like you know there's
like 60
60 to 100 people maybe you know it's
kind of a
it's a small like really intimate
setting
and so it allows me to be able to talk
to every single person that's there
and to like really get on ground level
with everyone and uh we got pro
skateboarders that come with us too
david reyes manny santiago
chazz ortiz like we we got a we got a
sweet crew fabrizio santos like
we've got a really fun crew and it's all
dudes that just love skateboarding and
love what skateboarding's done for their
lives and we all just want to
contribute what we can to you know not
to the less fortunate but just to people
that are
are feeling it it's good wow yeah that
always used to [ __ ] me up man like when
i was drinking and i was beating up on
myself and then i
see a story of somebody that's dying of
leukemia i'm like man here i am getting
[ __ ] up
and they would give anything to not
have this disease and that would just it
just make me feel so shitty dude
yeah i mean that's that self-pity you
know but it's like
no one could tell you that you were
gonna feel that pain
you know like no one can tell you hey
you should stop because you're going to
feel all this pain and you're not going
to like it it's like
i'm pretty hard-headed i have a feeling
we all are
i had to experience it myself you know i
had i had to get to that point where
i was fed up with feeling the way i was
feeling and and stop feeling sorry for
myself and actually do something about
it
and get healthy man i i got a lot to
contribute to the world and not only the
skate world just to the world
you know like i i feel i have something
to contribute
whether that's love whether that's
respect you know a solid role model
whatever it may be you know i can help
one person with my story and like
you know sobriety is cool it's cool yeah
you know yeah it is i'm enjoying the
[ __ ] out of it because i got sober right
before i turned 30 and i'm like [ __ ] i
wish i would have done this a lot
earlier i got seven 33 33 uh-huh
yeah yeah dude it's pretty rad to jump
on it early man
yeah yeah well man wendy farted again
dude look at her
[ __ ] dude did i uh open the door again i
don't know if it's that
if it's all right you guys love me was a
bomb dude okay
guys let me know i haven't caught this
one yet maybe you guys are just
like you built up a tolerance now so uh
your sponsors have been the same for how
long you've been riding for plan b
uh plan b since i was 15. so 15 years
now i've been on
oakley since i was seven years old i've
been on ethni since i was
seven just seven or eight um
yeah man i mean and those are like my
those are my my longest running sponsors
by far and it's just like
it's just loyalty bro it's loyalty it's
a family it's family at this point you
know it's like
and red bull man i've been on red bull
since i was 14 or 15 and
um i couldn't see myself being anywhere
else
you know it's like the the freedom that
these companies have allowed me to have
in projects that we do uh trips that we
want to go on whatever it may be
and especially with red bull it's like
you know like don't hit me up you want
to go to a formula one race i'm like
absolutely i would
you know like yeah you know red bull
does the coolest thing i was in taiwan
with red bull
and they were hosting the uh the
championship paper airplane contest oh
[ __ ]
and it was tight you know and i went
there and we threw out the first planes
and they were terrible but it was like
the fact that red bull is in every
type of sport every type of community is
like the coolest thing to me man and
they always include me
um me and my crew in it man it's like
it's amazing dude have you been to the
super high diving
no i haven't oh my god that shit's so
[ __ ] up i haven't
it's crazy like uh over a hundred feet
yeah
it seems off the side of the cliffs and
stuff yeah i watched it on tv
it's so crazy yeah red guy's like doing
flips and [ __ ]
like the difference with the super high
diving is that they land
exclusively on their feet they don't go
head first in like they do in the
olympics i wouldn't even jump off a
hundred feet late
dude they did like insane [ __ ] dude
yeah they're spinning and flipping the
whole way down
that's an important question i think
that the colorway action sports
the the whole like pressure in action
sports to just
constantly push push more flips more
twists more
higher [ __ ] jumps like it's uh
it's [ __ ] up you know smartly did you
see the documentary it's called the
crash reel
about the snowboarder kevin pierce and
he gets this traumatic brain injury
i saw that yeah and i know kevin
personally yeah wow yeah i never saw it
so it's
it's such a heavy indictment
of action sports in general because like
here
he was uh that dude the guy was on fire
man
yeah and the half pipe like it was the
the first olympics i want to say where
they
increased the height of the snowboarding
half pipe
by like a lot i don't know a lot and he
was training for it
and like did had this horrible [ __ ]
head injury
the guy's never been the same really man
you know and he was you know
he was the one that was going to be the
gold medal he was like gold medal
container
for sure by far because that's just ice
you're hitting like it's so unforgiving
right the half pipe it looks like snow
and like it's not so bad but it was so
[ __ ] up
yeah what was crazy to me was his
brother how self-aware he was
yeah you know it was like dude this guy
is more in touch with himself than i am
like it's [ __ ]
yeah yeah but but in any case
how much of that like i mean i i almost
feel like
what like pressure to do more pressure
to you know pressure to kick flip the
higher thing i mean none i got none now
no pressure bro it's crazy the pressure
the only pressure there is
would be whatever you know i put on
myself whereas before
i used to think that it was like
skateboarding as a whole was putting
pressure on me to do
bigger and bigger things and you can
kind of get pigeonholed
into that especially if
that's all you're showing people is that
you're jumping off the biggest things
and you're going the furthest and
you know all of a sudden these people
start putting you in a category of oh
yeah he's a jumper that that's what he
does he jumps so what's
he what's he going to jump next you know
and it's like
you almost can if you play into that you
can find yourself
jumping off something you know you can't
make just to try to
keep that going and so for me you know
being 30 now it's like with the injuries
that i've had
i'm i'm just trying to have fun again
and that's what i'm doing i feel like
i'm 13 years old again
body doesn't feel 13 but my mental is
like
ah i just want to skate i just want to
land tricks man
and yeah i'm going for gnarly [ __ ] still
i'm still going for gnarly [ __ ]
but [ __ ] that's within
within reality yeah it's it's within my
reality now and you know i used to look
at things i would have fantasy tricks
you know of like what i would do down
some spots and
um i don't even let my mind go play
there
anymore i'm just i skate more realistic
to
to what i can actually accomplish now
but red bull's not like
hey you should probably try and do this
or do they just stoked on whatever you
give them
red bull's just stoked bro they're just
stoked because they know i'm not
i'm not lowering my bar by any means i'm
actually more productive now that i'm
having
fun and i'm not worried about what
people think about my skateboarding or
if i deserve to be a skateboarder or if
you know if i've made it in skate like
i'm a skateboarder through and through
i've been skating since i was two years
old
you know you'll never take skateboarding
away from me
ever i'm a skateboarder i i've um
i've put myself in this world and and
i've stayed here and i love it
and so um at this point yeah it's just
about like
how much fun can i have and be gnarly
it's crazy watching you skate this
facility
like just home court advantage i mean
it's it's
watching ryan skate it it's to me it
seems like the complete opposite of what
he was talking about
preparing for a contest run because it's
just like oh
like all over just the spontaneous
tricks and all that you know
but see that happens when i'm having fun
but the second if
so yeah i could go in there right now
and probably could come up with a cool
one-minute run without thinking about it
but the second you
tell me it's a contest my whole minds
switch everything in my mind goes
whoa whoa whoa okay we have we have
preparation steps for this
period and we don't falter we do not
skate a contest without going through
these steps
fun skating that's exactly what it is
it's just fun
contest skating is gnarly you said you
still love competing i still love
competing
yeah i'm like i'm competitor through and
through
you can put a competitor with everything
else in life or just
absolutely absolutely i'm getting i'm
getting pretty fired up to skate dude if
you guys have any more questions
i actually have one thing i wanted to
bring up the other day we got we got
lunch we were all
getting tacos and you mentioned how like
wendy went missing
and then you ended up finding her and
you told me you were like
i knew i was gonna find her like and
you're like and i always had this
intuition where sometimes
i just know you're like i turned that
corner i knew i was gonna find her and i
found her or like i've been driving and
i
i know there's a cop coming around the
corner so i slow down and then there's a
cop
right can you talk about that a little
bit that intuition yeah man i feel like
i've always had a pretty like
pretty sharp intuition since i was a kid
you know
definitely like early teens i've always
kind of felt when a situation was
getting
either getting weird or or something was
going to happen or like
you know as simple as like a glasses
someone's going to knock that glass off
the table like
and all sudden it's it's shattered on
the ground it's like i've always i don't
know
i maybe it's god you know like i'm a
firm believer in jesus christ and
it could be god i could just be that i'm
super in tune with the world and what's
going on
um i feel like as a skateboarder you're
always super aware of your surroundings
you've always been
looking for street spots or looking for
something to skate so you're always
observing
everything that's going on and i just
think it's
it's it's something that it's just
something that i got you know it's just
like
normally my intuition is good and
normally i can listen to that
that voice in my brain and and know if
it's bullshitting me or not
and a lot of the times i've been able to
trust trust that inner voice and
and it pays off you know it's weird is
that what kind of told you like
i need to check myself into rehab i
should be sober because like
i can see this going for so bad for sure
absolutely um that had a that that
played a huge role and a lot of that was
like some of the only times i was trying
to ignore that
i was trying to ignore that voice
drinking like yeah i always got like
beat up on myself because i just felt
like you know when i was getting [ __ ]
up like i was just
at sixty percent my potential yep and i
was like [ __ ] i'm giving this gift and
like
yep if i died today i'd be like [ __ ] man
dude
you know such a funny way to describe
60 of my potential it's like no dude you
were
like going in the complete opposite
direction
like right yes i mean sixty percent you
still get sixty percent
but like but like climbing
wrong way i was down running a business
and so i was like operating
yeah right as a functioning person in
society
and i was like somewhat successful but
i'm like dude
i can be so much more successful sure
you know
right the number 60 came the same way
when you asked me how a movie was and
i'm like 86
like i just feel it you know like that's
scott's intuition
percentages like yeah redemption 98
yeah all right it's so funny all right
so
the last question is do you have any
advice for steve now that he turned pro
have fun bro yeah dude just keep having
fun man you're a huge role model and
you're a huge inspiration for so many
bro
well thanks man yeah when we were
skating last week you know i remember
thinking man i
got to figure something out and you were
like well if you don't figure something
out just have fun
yeah dude like [ __ ] a dude right on
it's all about
what's all about man it's just it's just
fun these days man yeah
that's cool and uh i mean i guess like
the
the corona virus is like the [ __ ]
whole world's crumbling around us
and you turned pro guys it's tough to
get boards
are you are you uh able to sell enough
boards
yeah i mean dude i feel like anything
that has to do with being outside right
now
is being
is a huge market skateboarding
skateboarding is doing great right now
some of the companies in skateboarding
are doing great right now and they're
selling tons of boards
looks like you're about to i guarantee
you'll you can you're going to sling all
of these bro
all of them i know i'll we'll never have
enough boards
um yeah i got it's a random question but
when plan b
got sold to uh wherever it got sold
uh did that affect your experience
as a pro for them um no
it didn't have no it didn't because i'm
i'm so
invested into plan b and to the team
and to the riders into the legacy of the
brand
that i just looked at it as just another
business
just another business transaction it
doesn't matter kids that skateboarding
adults that know what plan b is are
going to continue to buy plan b
and that's where we're at right now it's
like plan b is not going anywhere
it's a legacy brand and our team is next
level
and we're grinding bro and we're still
going
brothers are you trying to get me on
stevo
yeah dude skateboards yes
i would never do that and uh do you have
any mug shots
yeah dude it's a little bit of a
boutique
boutique break dude
i'm so glad i didn't jump on this board
and ride it i was like i saw it sitting
there i'm like i'm just gonna jump on it
i was like
dude it wouldn't have mattered i know
but then you're like
i know but i know how you can't remember
i'm [ __ ] getting ready to you can do
it barefooted
yeah with those walmart feet right there
and then wendy farts and i'm like
smelling it looking
at his feet like what all right dude
why hey man i don't have anything else i
just wanted to say thank you man no man
thank you guys bro
i appreciate this a whole lot man and
i'm just stoked for you like i feel like
you've had
a killer life and now
like with sobriety i think that what
really it represents
is for me anyway
it was like all right i i'm you know i'm
the stevo guy and it's like this
this whole thing and i'm so invested in
it i never know how to turn it off and
i've just got to be
this and then like i'm i'm afraid that
like i'm going to have the end of my
career then i'm just going to be useless
and worthless
and then sobriety for me represented
like some separation to work on
separating
like who i really am from this
ridiculous persona which i did
which i'm not you know and i feel like
as a as a pro skateboarder you know you
get
30 you're fine you know 40. look at tony
hawk he's in his 50s
but still i think that in almost
anything that you do and particularly in
anything like involving athletics you
got to like
kind of head into the later part of your
life
like with uh being comfortable being
ryan
right just that is that separation you
seem really comfortable in your own skin
and that's kind of what it's all about
yeah
yeah yeah i can't believe how
level-headed you are like if i was
16 and like rich and famous i feel like
i would be i'd be such a dick or
something like or i would have died by
now like it's so crazy how level-headed
with a ferrari
yeah but you know but like i was a
teenager and i was kind of a little bit
of a [ __ ] you know
but i i had but every teenager was yeah
it was hard
it's hard to say man it was like you
know i i had moments
that every kid growing up i mean maybe
not every kid like
i dude i didn't know anything different
than being a professional skateboarder
and traveling since i was a teenager
since the second i turned
13 i was professional and traveling the
world and
that's that's what i knew and so i
didn't sometimes i didn't know how to
act and
you know unfortunately the times i
didn't know how to act were on camera on
tv
and so it was like ah you know yeah you
live and you learn though
and um i've for sure learned from that
and and the biggest part about sobriety
and
my age now and what what's going on is
definitely being comfortable with
just me you know being stoked on the
skateboarder
ryan but also just being stoked on
you know just me yeah just being me
that's cool [ __ ] yeah dude
all right man let's skate dude and thank
you again thank you guys bro right on
yeah bro
[ __ ] hey man we did it again wild
ride with stevo another great episode
thanks to ryan sheckler
and hello street team i got a special
treat for you this week
as i mentioned in the in the podcast i'm
pro now professional skateboarder i was
excited about getting into his
park there and pulling off that kick
flip up the step up
it's very challenging for any pro skater
but of course i went in there and i
[ __ ] went after it like a bat out of
hell
oh yeah i dropped in i [ __ ] came
flying at that thing i flew up that step
up i
hooked it and i caught it clean i
cleared it by a mile the first trick i
landed on my pro model skateboard
really excited about that it's going to
be included
in a very epic what's called a part
a compilation of incredible skateboard
maneuvers which i will be launching at
some point
to uh announce my board to the world but
the street team
already knows about it so stay tuned
this pro skater signing off